es ist der große Vorwurf im Raum
Grenchen und die Grünen versinken im
Filz wir haben so etwas wie eine heute
der Ton von Markus Söder wir haben so
etwas wie eine Wende gewissermaßen wenn
die Grünen noch einmal von Filz und
Korruption sprechen können dann werden
sie verhöhnt und verlassen so am Samstag
aber auch bei der Nominierung mit äh wie
wir wissen nordkoreanischen
Verhältnissen 100% von Markus Söder in
großer Zustimmung große Zustimmung
Begeisterung
statt also was ich aber sagen will und
das macht es so dramatisch ich habe mir
ja mal die Freude gemacht diese Frage
von fehlt jetzt wäre billig nur zu sagen
das hat die Amigo Partei CSU seit
Jahrzehnten
Erfahrung wiederholen sich aber ich will
sogar sagen es gehört zur Folklore der
CSU das wissen sie allzu gut